sean is with us in baton rouge hey sean
welcome
to the ramsay show thank you i'm calling
um
i have a question about the baby steps
we're
we're self-employed and we're trying to
get on board with the baby steps and i
was just wondering
should we only have a thousand dollars
being that we're self-employed for baby
step one or should we have more
you're not making any money are you
we i mean well last 2019 we
the adjusted growth income was 188 000
okay then why are you worried why are
you worried about only having a thousand
dollars if you're making 20 000 bucks a
month
i'm just trying to do the baby steps and
my husband
i know but i mean you're making 20 000 a
month why can't why are you worried
about having a thousand dollars
i don't know i just i'm trying to make
it make sense
to him i'm like well that's i mean
that's that's a common sense
question for him yeah you have twenty
thousand dollars a month coming in why
are you worried about only having a
thousand dollars you got plenty of money
coming in
i mean if the world if you had a major
emergency you would just twist turn and
use that 20 grand and work it out right
yeah yeah because i'm like i'm trying to
get him to use the cash that we have on
hand and he's like no and
keep this in case of an emergency yeah
so
he's also the one that got you into debt
yeah
so his best plans aren't real good ones
right okay so
i'll let him go hey sean i got a great
thing for you you know
because we do this uh not just on radio
stations all around the country but
we're on youtube you can actually take
him to this moment rewind and let him
just watch it for himself yeah
so how much debt have y'all got how much
debt have y'all got honey
uh between the business and personal we
have like 229 000.
what's on the business the business is
110
that's like that's lines of credit and a
ppl loan
okay and uh what's the personal
the personal is 117 but that that
doesn't include the mortgage
and it's um it's a vehicle a heloc loan
the irs and a student loan
how much do you owe the irs 12 000
okay and what kind of net profit are you
making on this 188 000
what'd you pay taxes on that's what we
paid the
now the business brought in 950 000. oh
that's your actual
profit yeah yeah okay all right how long
have you been
how long you guys been running this
business
it's nine years okay all right
well this is uh i i started our business
on a card table in my living room
and i coach we coach businesses through
our entree leadership brand all over
america and have for decades
and um i can tell you what's happening
here
okay just by the information that you've
given me and this is not
i was kind of poking fun and being
sarcastic a while ago but now i'm
concerned
now i'm a little bit concerned okay you
have irs
debt you're making clear
close to 20 000 a month
and you're so discombobulated and
confused and there's so much chaos
so little organization your accounting
system sucks
that you still feel out of control
and this business it has grown so much
bigger than your ability to manage it
yes and so it's kind of like you feel
like you've gotten in a real powerful
car and you just learned how to drive
yeah i can hear it i can tell i can feel
the number i'm telling you i'm just like
what am i supposed to be doing here yeah
so
here's what we're gonna do i'm gonna
send you a copy of our book entree
leadership
on how to how to run a business it's
it's our playbook on how we've run our
business
it's not going to give you all the
information you need though you need to
get
with with a a different person
than you've been using to keep your
books
how many employees do you have none
we just have subs we uh it's a home
maintenance and remodeling business so
we don't have any employees we're just
we're 10.99 in the field
okay here's a book for you to pick up
too i'm going to give you two or three
assignments that are going to help you
with this because you're
you're classic you have become very
successful
and your success is going to be your
doom is how it feels
does that make sense yeah yes and i'm so
proud of you you've done
so well you and your husband okay this
is a great it's a great success
story but your lack of systems and your
lack of accounting
um is classic in your world
because your husband your husband is a
guy that can fix anything
he knows how to do any kind of
construction project and get it done
and he knows how to run the subs right
but he's done he hasn't ever learned and
and i had to do the same thing
and everybody that's in business said
learn to do the same thing you've got to
learn to run the business side of the
business the second book is called the
e-myth e-myth by gerber
okay by gerber g-e-r-b-e-r and michael
gerber says in that book
that you have to learn to work on your
business not just
in your business right and you guys have
been working
in the business and growing it up but
you've never stepped back and put the
accounting systems in place to control
the flow of the money because you've got
enough money to clean this mess up
really really fast when you get it
efficiently managed
that's what i that's how i can tell
that's how i can tell there's a bunch of
chaos
yeah yeah and you'll start you need to
start job costing each one of these jobs
separately
and that'll that probably involves an
estimating package
a good estimating package with a good
accounting software and so the third
assignment i'm going to give you two
books and an assignment
read those two books okay kelly if we if
we've got e-myth
just ship it to her if we don't just
ship her the information on how to get
an e-myth book but
um anyway then go to uh if you
go to daveramsey.com and click on tax
elp and find one in your area there in
baton rouge
that helps with bookkeeping and have
them come in
not to fix it all but to start to teach
you and your husband
how to do an accounting system
properly run that will help you get
control of this
because this money you're trying to out
i did this for years and
so i'm not trying not making fun of you
okay because i've done the exact same
thing i tried to out earn my stupidity
right i tried to work hard enough make
so much money
that it overcame my lack of systems and
my lack of accounting prowess and my
lack of other things
and you run too big a business now to
not increase your sophistication
it leaves you vulnerable to failure uh
that you don't need to feel the stress
that you're feeling
i know you're making a lot of money and
you're working your butt off and you
could have a lot more peace
than you have right now so you
desperately need someone in the
accounting world
to come in and go okay here's what job
costing looks like here's what cash
management looks like
here's what an accounting system looks
like and whoever's been doing it before
you before has not been cutting it so
they're gone you got to fire them
and you may need to hire someone as a
full-time
bookkeeper miniature cfo whatever we
want to call it controller
uh you know probably sixty seventy
thousand dollars a year you could put
somebody on
as a controller that could jerk a knot
in this tail pretty quick and get it all
straightened out and give you half your
life back
and you'd make more money as a result of
hiring them than they cost you
that's right they're spinning plates
right now and they've got to get some
simplicity that feels very complex
their business is fairly simple but i
think it's got all these moving parts
and what you're saying is right
once they simplify and get a really good
system
oh game changer now they know what to do
with the money now we can work the baby
steps and pay this debt off because the
beauty of
this is sean's husband is really really
good at making
money that's a fantastic it's a great
business yeah
to be in number one number two he's
proven that he's good at making it
the problem is that the thing's gonna if
you're not careful it becomes very
unstable like a house of cards and it'll
fall in on you that's right because all
the chaos
and the irs hadn't been paid we've got
all these other bills that hadn't been
paid off and we make plenty of money to
pay them all off right you could have
you could clear it in no time that's
right and that's why he's reaching and
saying i need more money in the savings
instead of a thousand dollars sure they
feel it yeah he needs he needs that pad
because he he
has all this volatility going on and uh
and all of that can go away with some
with some systems and some processes
uh in in the accounting world and
it's really not rocket science it's
stuff you could do on a yellow pad if
you knew how to do it
it's really not that hard but you just
gotta have someone teach you and say
this is how this works
and this is what you know you got to get
this in control and then let's lay out
some cash flow priorities
and let's begin to clear these debts up
you could clear them up very very
rapidly
you could be completely debt free in
your world in about two years
a hundred percent debt-free in two years
would that be wild that'd be wild